bonjour à tous je voulais vous parler
d'une invention formidable qui est un
petit radar embarqué très peu cher outil
qui permet dans les voitures de régler
la vitesse et surtout la distance entre
les différentes voitures ça permet
d'accéder d'agir sur l'accélérateur et
puis également sur la de frein si
la belle aventure se rapproche trop
cette technologie a été mise au point
pas très loin d'ici
entre autres à brest par grâce aux un
circuit intégré monolithique
hyperfréquences parce que pour calculer
la vitesse en face des tas de la vitesse
intéressant était d'avoir une modulation
linéaire complète mais avec des
plateformes de fréquence grâce aux mns
et s il faudrait qu'on fasse
alors quand j'ai parlé de ça magali
jeudi c'est génial comme si j'allais me
dis peut-être que ça sera un peu
segmentant alors j'ai dit j'ai un autre
fillette en place que vous avez envie
d'en parler depuis très longtemps aux
puces et la culture épicée la musique
c'est tout ce qu'on a appris récemment
sur le burgaud mort dorée à fabrice
temps glissante
elle m'a dit on l'a déjà fait alors bon
je lui ai dit ah ya un autre truc c'est
vrai parce qu'il ya des trucs
intéressants à creuser sur le bonheur
elle m'a dit ah ouais le bonheur je sais
pourquoi elle m'a dit ah oui le bonheur
parce que le bonheur est à la mode
jamais on n'a autant parlé du bonheur
qu'en ce moment on pourrait faire des
heures et des heures sur le bonheur le
bonheur sur les philosophes bonaldi
parle d'aristote bonaldi parc d'ariste
te rends compte le truc
ils égalisaient dix à vingt ans à canal
d'un équipement donc le bonheur selon
rabelais diderot voltaire le bonheur
sont dans la religion catholique
il ya le bonheur sans les physiciens
c'est un peu le deuxième période
deuxième principe de la thermodynamique
les physiciens de bonheur c'est une
sorte de pompes à chaleur il ya le
bonheur selon les neuro dire qu'en gros
le bonheur ça serait juste culture de
chimie c'est un peu de dopamine est
dedans de morphine qui est fabriqué par
les synapses
il ya le bonheur les coaches du bonheur
enfin en gros tout le monde parle du
bonheur
d'où toute l'importance de vous raconter
une vision un petit peu différente de
celle bonheur le premier s'appuie sur
une étude passionnante qui a été fait
par le crédoc
le crédoc qui a pris des gens comme ça à
panel très important et a demandé une
question toute simple bonjour je prends
des notes
lorsque je vous dis bonheur à quoi
pensez vous répondez librement tout ce
qui nous passe par la tête
l'intéressant c'est que alors les gens
ils répondent pour moi le bonheur c'est
un coucher de soleil moi c'est de dormir
à d'armitage dans des draps avec du
coton de de l'egypte nos petits dix mois
le bonheur c'est le sourire d'un enfant
c'est la pêche de ces deux jeux sauf la
banane de josselin le bonheur c'est
l'odeur de la route après la pluie le
bonheur ça serait d'avoir des pantoufles
connectés pas tout le monde dit ce qu'il
veut mener stallone travail des enfants
de la famille de mme aubenas et c'est
surtout intéressant c'est qu'ils ont
posé la même question exactement une
question ouverte en 2003 et en 2013 et
ce qui est intéressant c'est regarder
les différences ce que disent les gens
alors la fauche pas des notes parce que
c'est très sérieux
la première chose qui change peu c'est
la famille on parle autant de la famille
comme duke en 2003 qu'en 2013 en
revanche qu'on parle un peu plus de
l'argent et un peu plus de la santé en
gros en 2013
l'argent fait plus le bonheur on sait
bien que d'argent tebbal bonheur mais
qui contribue largement
il contribue un peu plus en 2013 qu'en
2003 nos jours sur la santé on se
préoccupe semble-t-il un peu plus notre
santé ce qui change en revanche c'est
très intéressant
ces notions de travail on me parle plus
mais surtout on parle différemment du
travail en 2003 le bonheur où on est
d'accord que cette fois les gens du
credoc prennent les variables et si
cavani mettre ensemble et lemm y mettre
les mots les mots tiroirs nemo outils
ensemble de façon à faire des blocs le
bloc travail et dans le bloc travail en
2003 c'était plus ascension hiérarchique
ascenseur social réussite
professionnelle tandis qu'en 2013 sur le
travail
il y avait beaucoup plus se réaliser
jeje avoir du travail craint un sens
mais que la notion du travail
elle a changé entre toujours sur le
bonheur le bonheur c'est quoi le bonheur
c'est d'avoir un boulot qu'un sens 2013
le bonheur c'est de réussir et nick et
mon patron 2003 un peu un petit peu
différent quand même la lotion bi-place
sont un peu différentes
vous avez vous dire les mots qui
reviennent plus souvent en 2013 qu'en
2003 2013 c'est hier sa pas beaucoup
beaucoup changé
les mots qui changent détente loisirs
vacances soleil tant voyage autres mots
qu'on utilise de plus en plus enfants
amis amour petits-enfants couple très
intéressant les mots qui n'était jamais
prononcée dans l'entretien ouvert en
2013 en 2003 mais qui se sont prononcés
en 2013
des mots qui n'existait pas on associer
pas du tout bonheur en 2003 on associe
en 2013
liberté liberté on découpe tranquillité
plaisir joie s'épanouir et profiter
juste vous dire qu'il ya une notion très
temporaire du bonheur et que le bonheur
il n'est pas immuable et qui changent
comment avec le temps
deuxième étude assez intéressante c'est
celle qui est faite par le on en voit
tous les ans c est ce que les français
sont heureux ou pas tous les ans n'a lui
on est plus heureux et portugais tiens
c'est toujours des danois qui se disent
les plus heureux et bizarrement n'est
plus heureux que les afghans sont plus
heureux que nous alors que bizarrement
et c'est intéressant c'est que tns
sofres en a profité pour faire une
grosse grosse étude grosse enquête
quatre mille personnes pour leur
demander leur poser un tas de questions
une flopée d'occasions est ce que vous
êtes marié est ce que vous avez des
enfants est ce que vous êtes en bonne
santé
est ce que vous avez lu qu'une pile de
malheureux il ya peu de temps est ce que
vous croyez en dieu est-ce que vous
jouer au tarot est ce que vous allez en
baisse de foot
est ce que vous aimez les les les
galettes saucisses enfin tout plein de
questions dans tous les ans dans tous
les styles et ils ont regardé après mais
indépendamment du goût de ubs vous êtes
heureux
ils ont regardé après est-ce que les
gens se disent heureux ils peuvent re
angot qu'est-ce qui était déterminant du
bonheur la question essentielle c'est la
fabrique de bonheur qu'est ce qu'ils
fabriquent le bonheur alors vous allez
voir les résultats sont assez
intéressants parce qu'ils sont un peu à
contre-courant de la pensée dominante
premier truc les enfants 3% de
discriminant ça veut dire que c'est pas
parce que tu as des enfants que tu es
heureux ou malheureux c'est pas parce
que t'as pas d'enfant théo malheureux
mais avoir des enfants ou pas avoir
d'enfant ça n'a aucune influence sur le
bonheur c'est exactement
est ce que vous êtes et ce que vous êtes
benga benko ça n'a pas
d'influencé enfants n'ont pas
d'influencé sur le bonheur autre truc
vachement important la religion 3%
la religion ce n'est pas discriminant
c'est pas le fait de croire ou ne pas
croire d'être croyant ou pas croyant
qu'ils fabriquent ou non le bonheur
mahler et on arrive au pire parce que là
c'est vraiment totalement dans la halle
1 à l'antithèse de ce qu'on dit
d'habitude la famille 0%
il n'y a aucune différence entre le
bonheur et de malheur des gens quand la
famille au compas tamis c'est parce que
tu as une famille que des malheureux ou
heureux c'est parce que t'as pas une
famille que tu es heureux ou malheureux
n'a aucune espèce d'importance
alors qu'est-ce qui va régler bonheur
premier truc mais c'est un peu une porte
ouverte
la santé la forme physique 11%
effectivement il ya 11 % de gens qu'ils
plus heureux qui tantôt bonne santé que
les qui ont de la forme physique 11%
également le cadre de vie bon évidemment
c'est habite à côté d'un truc typîque
bidonville des gens ils sont malheureux
le cadre de vie fabrique le bonheur
autre truc important l'absence de
d'épisodes douloureux si au moment du
sondage vous venait d'enterrer un copain
avoue évidemment là vous vous dites
malheureuse est coloré ce moment là
autre chose le niveau de vie leurs
revenus
là ça commence à devenir un peu plus
important c'est 16% mais le truc le plus
important qu'est ce qu'ils disent qu'ils
encaissent qui le plus marqueur de
fabrication du bonheur c'est 19% le
sentiment de contrôle de soi le
sentiment de contrôle de soi ou de la
société ce que les américains appellent
d'empowerment les psychologues parlent
du locus interne locus externe
le guide interne c'est quand je me dis
ce qui m'arrive
en bien ou en mal c'est à cause de moi
ou grâce à moi l'opus externe ces skiffs
d'assaut j'y peux rien c'est pas de ma
faute je sais ça me dépasse je peux rien
y changer le pij et puis de façon voilà
en gros quand on dit oui je suis maître
de ma vie on est heureux quand on issam
des pages de pub du voyage et pas deux
on est malheureux et ça est très en lien
avec le lien social
quand on quand on fait partie d'une
association née avec des copains quand
on joue au tarot au football ou qu'on
mange des galettes saucisses ensemble et
20 on est plus heureux c'est
l'empowerment c'est le fait de se dire
en fait l'idéal est de se dire je suis
maître de mon destin je peux changer
d'avis je suis autonome
je suis responsable là on est heureux
quand on dit je suis pas responsable
j'y peux rien ça me dépasse là on est
malheureux alors je vous propose
maintenant
de regarder si vous êtes heureux ou
malheureux de vous faire des tests c'est
relativement simple vous suffit de faire
cinq addition je vous propose le même
texte qui a été posé dans la france dans
l'europe entière le sondage est
internationale je vous pose je vous mets
une phrase est est-ce qu'on peut avoir
la première slide si vous êtes
totalement en désaccord avec la slide
avec le mot vous mettez un point s'il
est en désaccord de points légèrement
des accords trois points mis en accord
et c'est légèrement en accord cinq
points fortement d'accord 7.5 phrases
comme ça c'est un ollie main rassurez
vous on va vraiment vous demandez plus
c'est juste pour voir s'il commet ici
vous êtes heureux ou pas heureux
première phrase dans la plupart de ces
aspects ma vie est proche de mon idéal
vous compté dans votre for intérieur
prenez des notes si vous n'êtes pas
assez épais noir ou alzheimer dans la
plupart de ces aspects ma vie est proche
de mon idéal ça y est vous avez noté
qu'on ne boive omettez deuxième phrase
mais conditions de vie sont excellentes
1.2.3 points plus la petite phrase avant
ça devrait être bon troisième phrase je
suis satisfait ou satisfaite de ma vie
continue à compter en désaccord de
points ni en a connu à de l'accord 4
points 4e phrase
jusqu'à présent j'ai atteint les choses
importantes que je voulais atteindre
dans ma vie jusqu'à présent j'ai atteint
les choses importantes que je voulais
atteindre dans ma vie et enfin la
cinquième phrase si je pouvais revivre
ma vie je ne changerais presque rien
voilà ça qui a fait la somme des cinq
des cinq points est ce que on vous voit
mal mais est ce que ceux qui ont plus de
21 points vous pouvez lever la main
vous êtes très très vous êtes
très majoritairement plus heureux que la
moyenne des français
la moyenne des français c'est 21 vous
êtes mais la lie à ça ça transpire le
bonheur vous n'êtes plus heureux que la
moyenne nationale
bon elle est pas belle la vie bon alors
et c'était facile
c'est difficile parce que pour plein de
raisons la première vous n'êtes pas à
l'hôpital en train de vous faire opérer
la deuxième vous n'êtes pas chez le
notaire en train de divorcer troisième
vous n'êtes pas dans un cimetière en
train d'enterrer un proche est plutôt
vous êtes en bonne santé mais surtout
surtout c'est parce que vous êtes là ça
corroborent ce qu'on dit pas ce que
parce que vous êtes curieux parce que
vous voulez maîtriser votre vie parce
que vous pensez que vous qu'il est
possible de james gould 2 chainz qods
comme dirait sophie parce que vous
pensez qu'on peut changer le monde et
que c'est avec des petites choses que
vous le faites parce que vous êtes là
ensemble
vous n'êtes plus heureux que la moyenne
nationale ça sert félicitations vous est
terminée avec deux citations très
rapidement la première c'est monsieur
filosa le spécialiste du bonheur qui dit
le bonheur est une joie active
je crois que vous le prouver en ce
moment et le deuxième c'est plus récent
c'est jean louis trintignant qui disait
c'était à cannes quand il avait reçu un
prix spécial cannes cinéma
il disait et si et si on était heureux
ne serait ce que pour donner l'exemple
merci de donner l'exemple
alors
alors comme j'ai fait très très court et
que maintenant la diffusion s'arrête
j'ai pas fais des douze minutes exprès
j'ai été très très vite c'est pour qu'on
se fasse un bonheur vous êtes le bonheur
est communicatif il est carrément même
contagieux donc le bonheur des uns fait
le bonheur des autres participé à mon
bonheur
en faisant donc on va se faire un
bonheur ensemble je voudrais s'il vous
plaît parce que ce n'est jamais arrivé
d'avoir autant d'audience rennaise qu'on
reprenne une chanson connue dans le coin
qui commence par galette saucisse
s'il vous plaît alors s'il vous plaît
non mais attendez le bonheur ne vaut que
s'il est partagé par tous ça veut dire
qu'elles ont fait pas comme à l'église
ont fait pas semblant de chanter on sent
tous vraiment on chante tous vraiment je
vous en prie gas gas gas gas gas c'est
quoi
top c'était pas mal c'était pas mal
c'était pas mal pour une répète mais
vraiment pour une répète non il faut là
il faut se la faire bien si on viole pas
si on ne tente pas fort ça n'a pas
d'intérêt
il faut s' est puis vous êtes dans le
noir votre voisin il va pas vous
regarder on n'est pas la messe allez on
fait vraiment il ya un chanteur pour
donner le ton départ allez-y 1
et
c'est pas ma mère ça merci